so we're talking about the different
things that are changing in video
conferencing software now that it's
everywhere now that even
you know kind of my parents are video
conferencing other people to do yoga
and things like that so it's suddenly
become a key part of
nearly everybody's life but the
different companies are innovating in
different ways doing something slightly
different
we've all been in one of those calls
where someone's got the space background
or something like that you know so you
get these virtual backgrounds yes and
they somehow cleverly
with video analysis cut out your
your body and change the background and
we're not going into that today but
instead we're looking at what
that does for meetings and how people
feel with different settings and
whether any of them help people work and
collaborate and is it good enough to
replace
actual meetings there's decades of
research actually where people have been
trying to figure out
how to help remote teams to collaborate
and there's a few aspects to this
there's
computer-mediated communication as a
whole area
like how do you improve communication
when there's technology in between you
and the other person
and then there is team collaboration
tools to help you
manage your source code or you know book
meetings or somehow draw diagrams to
each other even though you're miles away
and then there's ways of creating
virtual environments that you can enjoy
and you can all go into that somehow
make it feel like you're in another
place
and all three of these things are
competing with each other for what might
be a good solution for
remote teams and a lot of time you're
asking yourself which ones do i need
do i need to be in a virtual world in
order to talk to someone
do i need collaboration tools for a
meeting
so it's a mixture of these different
aspects for what you want to have
a few years ago on computer file we did
something about telepresence thing where
you know
you 3d scan someone then they appear
somewhere else and you can chat to them
like you're in star wars or something
like that is that what we're going for
here
well they're really interesting because
they often match a little bit of the
research theory as to what's going to
happen and then the research sort of
copies a bit what the science fiction
films do
but you've seen it probably in star wars
where there's six of them sat round in a
kind of
circle and one of the people in the
circle is a hologram and they're
joining in just like they're in the room
and you kind of feel like that would be
the ideal situation but what those
often hide is that like the reality of
what that one person is seeing at their
end
because they probably don't have five
empty chairs with five holograms in it
they would have a computer screen with
maybe like little people in it and they
in the films they magically look to the
side when they want to talk to yoda who
sat there but you know in practice they
would be like
scrolling on their screen to the next
person or something
and you wouldn't get the actual like
it's simulated very nicely in film but
not yet happening
in the real world yeah so microsoft
teams have added this new feature called
together mode
and we spent about 45 minutes together
with about what was that 10 of us
the other day doing a quick example and
it's purposely changing the way that you
see
everybody on in this case microsoft
teams
but it could be on zoom if they had the
same sort of thing implemented
and what it does is it puts everybody in
the meeting into one room
a bit like you're in a meeting room and
you included in that are all sort of
spaced out in this space
when you first talked to me about this
idea i said this sounds like an
absolutely ridiculous gimmick so let's
have a look at it
and i have to be completely honest my
experience was
at the time oh this is a bit of fun but
the reveal was when we click back to
gallery mode
and then you suddenly see all of these
off-putting backgrounds behind people
someone's in the kitchen someone's in a
bedroom someone's in an office there's a
book behind someone someone's got a bike
over there suddenly there's a lot more
information that that's off-putting
that's how i felt
it's certainly true like there's we have
a regular meeting on wednesdays
and every time that seems to be the time
our friends has their window cleaner
come past
and so all the meetings has got one
window cleaner in the background
and it's um there's one thing it does is
it just removes all the backgrounds a
bit like the virtual backgrounds but at
the same time it then takes
all the foregrounds and puts them into
one place and you're right you do lose
lots of
varied backgrounds and it takes a lot of
your visual processing away from what
you have to do
the the other thing that was interesting
was for me
and i think this is something they could
fix if they put a bit of time and effort
in was the scaling
so uh you know depending on what bit of
equipment you're using
where it is and you know you basically
get different views on people and
different sized people and different
yeah that's actually part of a much
bigger issue but you're right when we're
in the teams if someone's leaning
forward like this and their camera is
here
then you they've got this massive head
and then someone's leaning back over
here
you can relax and they're a little teeny
person but you're all on the same size
chair in this view and it's
a bit weird to see it um but camera
angle
and position of the camera in relation
to the screen
is one of the things that makes um
online meetings quite difficult
like video conference meetings because
uh ideally
if you're in a physical space like this
one we're in uh there'll be one person
in each chair or at the moment you know
one person every two meters away on
these chairs and when someone down there
talks you'll look at them
and that would work in theory but if my
camera's here and my screen's here then
i spend the whole meeting talking here
and then when i look
the camera i'm like this and so you're
all over here and i'm
it's the separation of camera and screen
is the thing that creates
part of the problem and what it means is
that you don't know what people are
looking at
you don't know if they're looking at you
and if everyone wants to talk to
jane over there then not everyone's some
people have gone oh
and some people have looked up to this
bit because they've got teams on this
part of their computer screen and
there's
i have two screens at home and you know
i have teams over here and
my work over here so when i'm looking at
the people i'm like this and it's
the separation of where you're looking
and what you're talking to is
a big aspect of what makes it hard for
people to know what to do
and this is part of non-verbal body
language if you have a whole upper body
rather than just a head or just head and
shoulders then you immediately increases
rate of co-understanding as to what's
happening so there's been experiments
where they say you know this is what
we've discussed in the last meeting
which of these things do you think was
true
and they take simple ratings like that
or simple questionnaires and you realize
that people
get a better understanding from a
meeting very quickly if you can see all
their body language
and everything like are they
disappointed by something that's just
been said or
you know who are they turning to i mean
an obvious one is folding the arms right
yes yes i'm not at all happy with that
one thing this together mode is supposed
to do is have spatial consistency
so one thing in if you're not on
together mode is that
on your screen you might have i might
have steve here and dave there
and me down here i was a little bit in
the corner and then on steve's computer
it's the opposite way around um but in
together mode everyone gets a seat
in the room and they're in that seat for
everybody who's looking at together mode
and so you can do things like when
someone talks everyone does look a
little bit to the same chair
and so you get spatial consistency kind
of built in so that was one thing that
we're going for
how do you get it so you get spatial
consistency in a
video conferencing meeting and one
solution was to put you
and everybody in one space have a fixed
position that replicates on all the
screens
and that builds at least some element of
spatial consistency that's not been
there before
there are loads of challenges with this
but does it make that much
difference to people if you make a minor
adjustment
so one of the aspects is it's called the
cone of gaze and it's to decide whether
someone's looking at you
and that's part of as i mentioned
earlier the kind of um whether you trust
what someone said or whether you
understand effectively what they said or
whether they whether you think someone's
talking
even to you when they've said something
should happen so sometimes in a meeting
we'll say is that something you can do
for the next meeting
and there's you don't explicitly say you
know i want to i want sean to do this
for the next meeting
um so you have to start adding that in
your speech to make sure everyone
understands it so it adds overload or
overhead to your speech
um but if you can make it so that things
like uh
gaze is seemingly directed at the right
person then having the special
consistency in teams means that
if you did look over there uh to the
person in the top
who's in the top left seat and everyone
sort of looked towards them you can even
point towards them a little bit which we
did in the meeting
that creates some of the reliability or
understanding
but what you have to try and get is the
sense that actually the eyes are looking
at you
and as you said it really you can really
tell if someone's looking at the camera
or you just a little bit so
there's a specific angle of called the
cone of gaze where if you're within a
certain
five degree angle then it looks like
someone is looking
plausibly at you then that will be
what you want to try and recreate so
there's other versions of research where
they've tried to
replace your eyes with a little bit of a
of an angle so it looks like your eyes
are actually just a little bit to the
left so you're looking at someone
but that starts to look a bit freaky and
all the best examples we've seen i'm
imagining one of those paintings in kind
of the horror movie where
there's a cut out bit where the eyes are
yeah yeah you can see where people are
going they're trying to make it so that
it looks
like in real life that you've all looked
at someone and if you've got spatial
consistency that's one step towards
making it look like you've all looked to
the same place in the screen if you're
looking at them
we've had some fairly good results with
that i mean presumably that's just
geometry in a way it's like doing some
clever stuff with where your webcam is
where your seat is in the space
webcam close to where you're looking on
the screen presumably you haven't got it
full screen on your big 27-inch
or in your big 40-inch tv at home
then having the webcam near to where
you're going to look anyway
i mean i struggle with this with
lectures and i've got lecture notes that
i'm
reading out to the students and i'm
looking to see what like what slide is
showing
and that's off away from my webcam and
if there's notes about what needs to be
said in a lecture then you're looking to
the side for where those are so i
find myself trying to look at the camera
and then see what's next and then look
at the camera to deliver the information
and then go so next point
so it's yeah a big challenge to feel
like you're looking at someone
and that's what most of the software is
trying to recreate to make video
conferencing a little bit easier
so one of the other approaches that a
company took was mozilla and they had
mozilla hubs
and the idea there was they were
borrowing from these open world things
like world of warcraft or second life
where
you create a 3d virtual environment you
can go into
using whichever technology you want to
but the idea is everyone
is made even and spatially consistent by
going into
a virtual world where you have a
character that you can style to look
like yourself
and then you can do things like have
posters or
presentations that you go to a bit like
at a conference
so you would walk around inside a kind
of 3d vr environments
i was going to say so this is needing
kind of headsets and all that sort of
stuff not necessarily i can't remember
now whether you can access mozilla hubs
via vr kit but you could still do it
through your computer screen but as
you're moving around on
the computer you see basically other
people over there and you move in the
space
using the controls and so when they see
you coming to this place
is that open for anyone to try or was
that something they were doing
internally open
for general use i think of it's still
there um but it's
yeah you could just host meetings on
mozilla hubs you get a special id
like a url to log into and uh you just
joined meetings that way so
various bits of the university were
having their weekly meetings in those
spaces so they could
sort of sit together in a space and
watch a presentation on the screen
is that you over there i don't know i'm
just stood by the river hello yeah
that's me i'm the soldier
all right there you are so this is
yeah we're in a i don't know space
what happens if i turn the camera on do
you see like my head
above it oh yeah i'm seeing something
there
i'm seeing a green thing it looks yellow
to me
oh okay it might just be it's yellowy
green it's yeah it's probably a yellow
it's
i don't know what that yellow thing is
though that's that's perhaps a shared
screen type thing isn't it
we've left it there yeah they'll just
put it over there and we can move around
so you can see this is the exciting
alternative having being in a 3d world
yeah that's you that grey robot thing
right
yeah it becomes interesting
exploring another world like it's a
computer game in a way um but it's
supposed to democratize the idea that
you're all
in a space you're on a shared space you
can move around it
and it's not a kind of weird being in a
behind a computer screen experience but
you're somehow together an event
or you know well i reckon you know i
could be sat in my car on a break
between driving somewhere and join a
meeting there and you wouldn't know if i
was in an office
in a car or whatever right so it's i
suppose it's
assuming you've got a connection and
then that's what everything comes down
to right
the thing this sort of thing loses
though is the body language you lose
that straight away so that's one of the
things that's been shown to encourage
trust is that you
or understanding is that you can see the
body language and
what expression their face is making you
want to know whether someone doesn't
agree with what what you're saying or
think you've said something stupid
well nobody can see now is me shaking my
head
number of bites to come in before we can
send the packet out
that's going to introduce some latency
so we need to make sure we choose a
packet size
that is small enough to not introduce
too much latency
so let's say we just had one town the
man
goes sounded to me 20 years ago when i
first stumbled on this very much